thank you uh yeah sir uh this is just
simply mesmerizing chess up to at this
point can you remember the last time you
started off with 5-0
um
at least not in the granchester um
yeah but this was a gift so it was he
just um
he just blanked out you talked with him
a little bit after the game what did you
guys discuss did he miss this move
knight takes e4 or what was his miss no
i'll tell you he after d e5 instead of d
e5 should i just type it yes absolutely
he thought
he later on said he should have played
knight c4
and the idea instead of the e5 yes and
if i go
ed4 then he takes on d6
and
if rookie 6 then knight f5 that is
correct yeah
but
suddenly i'm seeing that instead of
rookie 6 i can play
queen c7
c7 and if you take queen to g3 oh you
can just take it oh the pawn is still on
the performance on default okay
so that was uh
so uh in fact this might be more
reasonable for him i mean i i was
surprised he went for g4 because i
thought i'm already better
but uh if i have to play bishop c7 then
it's entirely under control because he
no it does seem that taking and then
rookie six five maybe take on c3 and
knight c5 or something yeah it's gonna
be okay for me
he has some compensation of course but
actually there's no pawn down so
it's just a normal position uh and he
played take on e5 knight takes eve well
this now he's as far as i could see he
was just like he's just lost here i mean
i'm maybe i'm overly i also knight d4
still wasn't clear to me
but um
i was thinking d5 f4 d4
uh
no it's not that
that the computer likes
so what should i play here instead some
knight
takes g4 or something i mean i was going
to sit and think of it but i was
expecting knight d4 because i almost
thought it's only move
after knight e5 rook e5 i don't see a
defenseman if he goes king g2 i go d5
and this is what he had
he missed at the end
so
and once again this computer is
irritating me by saying that i'm
completely wrong
we both hallucinated then because we
thought this is game over but now i see
that rook f1 and it keeps white
is the only move yeah that is
embarrassing i spoiled the mesmerizing
thing but um ah so we just both
miscalculated perhaps
and he panicked yeah we just missed rook
from the end because it looks like
otherwise white can resign you cannot
handle
and somehow the problem is when you have
a bishop on g6 you don't think the f7
pawn is going to drop
and so
a little bit of that oh so king g2 is
still playable then and then uh
okay so we were both we were both in
another world i mean i was surprised he
was surprised and then
he went for this of course and now he
should cut his losses and take on e4
already i'm not sure that i don't have
bishop f2 check
but the way he did it uh it's just two
designs i mean and three points up for
something so
no he just um
he just blue screened so that was it uh
everything is connecting perfectly right
now for you did you do anything
differently for
this tournament in preparation or is
just everything gelling together
i don't know
i didn't do anything
very different
i tried to get back into shape and
i mean the first game in the day was
quite good i think uh there was a good
uh admittedly his e4 wasn't uncalled for
i think
but once he did it i thought i did a
decent job maybe the only thing was
i needn't have allowed him b4 quite as
fast with knight d3
there were still some other moves maybe
if i played g4 or something i'd have
been even even happier with my play
but uh that was a good game this one
i think it's not lemon's level and i'm
not going to pretend it is
good vibes definitely a lot of
confidence for you vichy we're looking
forward to see you in the next game
thanks guys back to you thank you
christian thank you